thank you yasser we are with a wesley
saw wesley first of all commiserations
uh for this match tell us what are your
first feelings after this match
uh
well sam's a very strong opponent i
think he played very well taking nothing
for men off from him also big congrats
to him for reaching 2700 for the first
time i believe so it's
gained almost 50 rating points the last
few months is working hard i also
like
played before some practice games with
him and he's
i always have a bad result with him
remember 2015 i lost him with white when
he was 2500 so it wasn't an ideal
pairing but
not many excuses but i also wasn't
feeling well the start of the tournament
and i started very poorly and slowly
but uh
i'm a just professional so i love what i
do i'm glad to be back in saint louis
and
we'll come back and fight another day uh
i think uh yesterday i was doing well in
the opening like i had some bandage
after my preparation so that's one good
sign but uh obviously mistakes were made
here and there but
um
there is what happened there at the end
yeah when you play that move bishop to
e3
because we saw sam uh on the camera it
felt like he was disappointed i think he
spotted that whole variation uh how did
you feel about that position
at that point yeah he did actually he we
were analyzing after the game and he
pointed this rook c7 move to me
later on and
i was very shocked because uh
i mean i clearly had the worst position
for many moves already
and it was or i thought it was already a
miracle if i could save the game and
when he played d3 which i underestimated
i thought the game was just over because
queen is a bishop f5 broke g7 q h5 but
so i lost i
a little fast for our audience if we
cannot bring up the board maybe
in my audience i mean for me
yeah we lost everybody there oh sorry oh
yeah this was yesterday's game oh yeah
this crucial moment where you were
mentioning that when your opponent sam
has played this move d3 you had inwardly
given up you thought the game's over and
you didn't recognize that you had this
opportunity and you were shocked when
sam pointed out to you yeah you made
something very shocking very good
lucky also i had eight minutes here but
i barely even used any of my timing
while sam had two minutes so i so you
did not see this variation of queen
takes d three bishop f bishop f5 rook
takes g7 you had probably saw this i
just saw this and i thought i refined i
resigned okay and then sam said do you
realize that you had this move
rook c7 which sets up bishop c3 and then
you were shocked
yeah of course i was shocked i mean uh
yes i said i
probably
lost all hope when i saw the move the
theater it was over you stopped after
queen h5 right yeah definitely queen h5
i thought i lost i thought i lose my
queen
and i didn't even see bishop c3 like
here
in february 7 bishop theatre is also
losing but at least i only lose a piece
after queen c5 but rook c7 actually and
black has to find and only move in order
to make a draw so
not rook not bishop c3 because you
you're pointing out that you your
opponent has queen c5 but rook c7
and even though you're an entire queen
down
you're right back in the game this is
actually an amazing position i mean
truly i don't have two pawns for the
queen but
black is almost lost so this is almost a
study right in a way but yeah yeah i
just stopped thinking after queen h5
exactly but roxy seven now black have to
find rookie seven yeah rookie seven in
order to save the game but it would be
incredible if black actually even loses
rook e7 but i think yesterday i was
happy with the outcome the opening
uh but just wrong rook moves like rpg
one dopings if rook hd one was a mistake
and uh
and uh yeah and also allowing the bishop
to get the g7
was
fun but an interesting game i actually
was preparing that opening in the grand
prix in berlin so it's not a good deal
for my purpose
that's terrible
it's great
then you just blow it i've been saving
it for three weeks
speaking of prep wesley i have to ask
today you were in a must-win situation
with the black pieces we were perplexed
here in the studio by your choice of
opening we thought you'd get into
something a bit more fighting but it
felt that you got a position just a bit
unpleasant with no chances to win what
inspired you to play this particular
variation yeah that's true i just
thought today i'd be happy to play an
end game like any end game basically uh
trade the queens because sam is
very strong tactically and i can't like
end games so like berlin or something
and the
i was analyzing this position in berlin
because my opponent is played
and i thought it's interesting i mean
the problem is my opening repertory
black is very limited mostly
uh i mostly play solid lines like nimso
stuff and so it's not so easy and also i
thought that sam would play e4 first of
all so it wasn't really bird for d4 so i
thought i just played the end game but
it's the first time i played this line
and uh
i
obviously misplayed it i mean allowing
the pawn to h6 is a very bad decision by
me like yes when the pawn got here he
has a knight h5 g7 idea yes
so to everyone who played this end game
with black i mean kramnik has to play
this end game so i mean it's very solid
and
black of the bishop player i thought if
sam's not expecting this if white makes
in a core assistant black would start
playing for a win but it didn't work out
also like
i think my mistake was allowing the pawn
h6 i should have played bishop f5
earlier here right just a one moment
after knight f4 so i think bishop f5
here right here this was the moment
where you you should have played there
and probably black has no problems but
of course as you say it's very hard to
win the idea is that after bishop d3
bishop e6
um here black is fine because i'm gonna
play f5 and if h5 i always have h6
so that's the main
that's the main consideration yeah but
uh
yeah obviously i mean i think like if
fabian has to play for a win with black
he would play some g6 or the king's
indian but unfortunately i
just simply don't play those openings i
don't play the modern
and i'm not magnus carlton unfortunately
but
we'll bounce back
all right well thank you wesley for
joining us and good luck in uh
the rapids that you you have you only
have one life left now
i'm not the cat
[Laughter]
thank you wesley yeah thank you oh thank
you
and in his second chance you see there
the elimination bracket wesley saw